[Music]
hello and welcome to today's episode of
The Power of Words I'm your H SAA and
today we're going to discuss a topic
that affects students parents teachers
and society as a whole Bing in
school Bing is a complex attached in our
institutions for Generations it is a
problem that often remains hidden yet
its impact can be found very destructive
today I'd like to delve into the world
of school Bing explore its forms its
consequences and most importantly how we
can get rid of it first let's define
balling it's not just kids being kids or
a right of passage Bing is a pattern of
aggressive behavior that is repeated and
evolves an imbalance of power
occurs everywhere even in in the highest
performing schools and it is hurtful to
everyone involved from the targets of
buling to the witnesses and even to
bullish themselves it can manifest in
several ways such as physical verbal
relational and now in the digital age it
can be cyper balling physical balling
includes actions like hitting or
stealing someone belonging
verbal buling involves name calling
insults or spreading rumors relational
buling is about harming a person's
social standing by excluding them or
manipulating their relationships cyper
balling the most recent addition uses
technology and social media to harass
others so what are the consequences of
Bing the effects can be long lasting and
severe victims often experience anxiety
depression and in worst cases can even
self harm or suicide also the fear of
Bing can lead to a lack of motivation to
learn but Bing doesn't just harm the
victims it can have a lasting impact on
the balles as well engaging and Bing
behavior is often indicative of
underlying emotional or psychological
issues if left unaddressed these
problems can persist into adulthood and
contribute to a cycle of violence or
other harmful behaviors but what would
what can we do to address and prevent
Bing it starts with open
communication encourage students to talk
about their experiences and feelings let
them know that it's okay to ask for help
for parents and teachers it's vital to
listen without judgment and take all
reports of Bing
seriously education and awareness are
key schools should implement antib in
programs that educate students about the
consequences of their
actions these programs can help create a
school culture where balling is not
tolerated students need school to be a
positive climate where they feel safe
this reduces their own stress and
potential aggression allowing them to
focus on the learning necessary for them
to be successful in their lives the
causes of buling are varied meaning any
student can become a Target regardless
of gender race religion or socioeconomic
status understanding Why students bully
others can help teachers better combat
it factors that can lead to bullying
include differences in appearance social
status race and sexual
orientation some students who bully
others have low
self-esteem however there are others
that have much higher selfconfidence
those with high self-confidence tend to
lack compassion and empathy and can
respond aggressively whenever they feel
threatened in some cases students need
for attention and the desire to be
perceived as Brave and confident can
cause them to bully students who
experience issues at home such as abuse
or divorce can cause them to bully
others due to anger or jealousy but
which people have a high risk of being
bued we think that children with
disabilities such as physical
developmental emotional and sensory
disabilities are at an increased risk of
being bullet any number of factors such
as physical factors social skill
challenges or intolerant factors may
increase the risk research suggest that
some children with disabilities May
bully others as well kids with special
Health needs such as epilepsy or food
allergies Also may may be at a high high
risk of being bullied bullying can
include making fun of kids because of
their allergies exposing them to the
things they are allergic to in these
cases Bing is not just serious it can
mean life or death cyberbulling is a
particular concern in our digital age
schools sh should educate students about
Online safety and consequences of their
actions there are also websites that at
to addressing and preventing Bing
offering resources and support to those
affected legal consequences should also
be in place ensure that there are clear
consequences for Bing behavior when
students understand the seriousness of
their actions than they may think twice
before engaging in balling technology
can play a significant role in
addressing and preventing bullying
authorless reporting systems in school
can provide the safe way for students to
report incidents social media platforms
should enforce tricker policies against
hyper buling and provide easy ways to
report abusive Behavior preventing
buling in schools requires a multifaced
approach that involves students teachers
parents and the community here are some
essential steps that school can take to
prevent Bing educate students teach
students about the different forms of
Bing the negative consequences and how
to recognize and Report buling Behavior
this education can be integrated into
the curriculum and reinforced through
workshops train staff provide training
and for teachers and support staff on
how to recognize address and prevent
buling ensure that staff members are
equipped to respond effectively and
support victims support victims Provide
support and counseling services for Bing
victims ensure that they have access to
resources to help them cope with the
emotional and psychological impact of
balling celebrate diversity Embrace and
celebrate diversity within the school
Community encourage tolerance and
acceptance of people from different
backgrounds cultures and abilities
preventing Bing is an ongoing process
that requires the commitment and
involvement of everyone in the school
and
Community it's essential to create an
environment where all students feel safe
respected and
valued in conclusion balling in schools
is a complex issue that we all know by
creating a culture of open communication
education and support we can make a
positive impact in our schools and
communities remember it's a conversation
that truly matters Belling is a critical
issue that demands our attention it's
important to know that there are
solutions and support systems in place
Bing is a social issue that we all need
to take responsibility
for by raising awareness educating our
children and actively working to prevent
and address buling we can create a safer
and more inclusive place for students
thank you for joining me on this episode
of The Power of word if you found this
podcast informative important and
helpful please share it with others who
need to hear this message until next
time let's work together to end balling
take care and be kind to others